2. television for serious readers
welcome to the hudson institute i'm
brian clark a senior fellow at the
institute and today we're here to talk
with chris rose whose new book the kill
chain
uh defending america's uh
defending america in the future of
high-tech warfare uh that chris bros uh
just released uh chris is a former staff
director for the senate armed services
committee prior to that he was the
senior policy advisor for senator john
mccain
and previously held other positions in
the government
right now he is the chief strategy
officer of andrew industries that builds
capabilities for the military as well as
the department of homeland security i
believe we can talk about that as we go
through this interview but welcome chris
thank you very much for being with us
today
oh thanks brian it's great to be here
so uh just to start off with what kind
of led you to do this book i know you've
been thinking about these issues for a
while and uh obviously this is something
you've encountered a lot uh during your
several years both on the armed services
committee and advancing senator mccain
as a policy advisor um but what was the
the genesis
that led to you really sitting down and
writing an entire book
yeah it's a great question i asked
myself that constantly
why did i get into this every day i was
working on it
um i'd say i guess it was basically two
things um one was and you know both of
these were kind of a product of the many
years that i spent working on these
issues when i was in the senate and um
you know just kind of thinking about
this stuff on a day-to-day basis
the first was just sort of the growing
realization in the years that i was
there that you know we just had a
fundamental problem that i felt was kind
of under-appreciated it's not to say
that people didn't appreciate that we
were losing competitive advantage uh
that we weren't where we needed to be
from a technological standpoint and you
know to a certain extent an operational
standpoint
it was mostly just the sense that i
didn't think there was the urgency to
get after that problem that that we
needed considering how fast that problem
was closing on us and in some respects
actually i think how far would you know
behind that problem we actually are
right um the second was really then sort
of
again the thinking that i had been doing
around what do we do about this
and you know on the one hand uh there's
a lot of talk about um you know the
threat and sort of the operational
problems presented by a pure competitor
like china
there's a lot of talk about technology
and sort of the importance of emerging
technologies like artificial
intelligence and autonomous systems uh
to really being
essential to you know kind of enhancing
america's competitive advantage from a
military standpoint
it didn't feel to me though that there
were kind of concrete answers coming
together so it's like what do i do with
this new technology how does it allow me
to think differently build new kinds of
capabilities operate in different ways
that are actually going to create
competitive advantage for the united
states military um you know there's sort
of a sense that
we were talking about these technologies
you know as like we're just going to
layer them on top of the things we've
always had and the way we've always
operated and we're just going to be able
to do it better right right so you know
from my standpoint look i mean i uh you
know i i i sort of was living at the
nexus of these worlds um you know from
the technological standpoint uh you know
really i think you know on the hill kind
of looking at the emergence of these
technologies kind of the dods treatment
of them attempt to develop them
and then obviously kind of looking at
the operational problems and threat
briefings and uh you know discussions
with with the department of defense
um
you know so my my view on it was okay is
there a way to sort of help bridge this
divide or this gap between you know what
it is we think we might be able to do
with new technologies and what are the
things that we are going to need to do
or want to do differently from an
operational standpoint um and sort of
you know in a broader strategic context
kind of where are we going what is the
what is this next kind of era going to
look like um and that that was
essentially the origins of it and
honestly it was more of an attempt for
me to get my own you know sort of head
around these problems uh you know as it
was to sort of say like here's here's my
contribution to what i think the answers
look like right
so uh
and i totally agree that we are at a
kind of a juncture where we need to make
some decisions as a as a nation and as a
department of defense on how we're going
to deal with the problem that in
particular china poses but more pretty
much any high-tech competitor is going
to pose because we still are lugging
around a very legacy military that's not
quite changed how it operates or changes
how it's postured to take advantage or
exploit new technologies that are
becoming available so it seems like one
thing you're really focused on is the
idea that it's not just about you know
building these new technologies because
arguably they've been around for a few
years and andrew even you know does some
of this work obviously
it's about changing the way that we're
going to use the way we're going to
fight the way we're going to use these
technologies in terms of the operational
concepts
and you talk a little bit in there about
the idea of human command and machine
control which i think is an interesting
way of of describing what the department
often characterizes as manned unmanned
teaming which kind of makes it seem like
the man system the unmanned system are
on and even are on par with one another
and they're going to go out and you know
act as a team and and if they get
separated they can operate independently
and if they come back together they can
team up again which is obviously not a
correct way to characterize or consider
the the introduction of unmanned or
autonomous systems so how would you how
do you think of that that new way of
operating that we're going to then need
to embrace with the advent of autonomous
systems and then we can maybe talk about
ai as a as an added element to that
yeah for sure um so first off to give
credit where credit is due uh human
command and machine teaming was your
phrase uh that you can you know coined
with dan pat
uh which i which i give credit to both
of you in the book for um and i think
you actually
uh it encapsulated the way i thought
about it very nicely which is why you
know i sort of you know gave it pride of
place um
the the reason i don't like machine uh
manned unmanned teaming is yeah the
sense that the sort of demand and the
unmanned system are equals
um and that they're somehow on equal
footing um which which i which i just
dislike um and i think the other piece
of it is
there sort of is this tendency to
believe that you know these new
technologies are just so fundamentally
new and different that you know the way
that we've always thought about you know
kind of the control of military
operations all of the law policy norms
and procedures that have sort of
governed this in the past are somehow
going to be thrown out the window
because this stuff is just fundamentally
different
my own view is that it just isn't it's
it's going to be much more of a you know
kind of movement along a continuum um
from where we have been than sort of
some brand new uh you know brand new era
um and ultimately i think it really does
kind of come back to this question of
command and control which is you know
again a very familiar military concept
and i think it's helpful to sort of take
the systems out of it and really kind of
get to the question of
what we're ultimately talking about is
the performance of military tasks
those tasks are going to continue to be
performed the question is sort of who or
what is going to be performing them
um you know you're still going to have
superior
actors who are controlling subordinate
actors
traditionally you know that's been human
superiors commanding uh human
subordinates
but i think as these systems become more
intelligent and more autonomous um you
know some of those kind of lower more
technical kind of repetitive tasks more
mundane tasks
that take an inordinate amount of human
time in the us military right now i mean
we have tens of thousands of humans who
are doing processing exploitation
dissemination uh you know of sensor
information um just as one example
you know increasingly more of those
tasks could be performed by you know
more intelligent more autonomous
machines um that doesn't mean that
they're going to just be off you know
kind of like doing it on their own
um you know it's still going to be again
through the same architecture framework
of command and control now where where
humans set very clear
parameters for you know the control of
military tasks um you know you're going
to test significantly and train
significantly the subordinate actors who
are going to perform those tasks and in
the process of training and testing
you're going to build trust that they
can do the thing that you are giving
them responsibility to do
you know that we talk about autonomous
systems as if you know uh there is such
a thing yeah the reality is autonomy
describes the relationship between a
human who is delegating tasks to someone
or something uh other than that
so you know in that respect i think it's
really more around
um you know sort of what are the what
are the standards by which we are you
know going to be able to come to trust
machines to perform tasks that currently
uh or or sort of uh previously only
machine or only humans could perform um
but i don't think the way in which we're
going to do that is going to be any
different than the way that we
uh that we sort of evaluate humans in
that respect or evaluate uh you know
kind of less intelligent machines that
we've been relying on for a very long
time
you know
we have processes in place to do this
um you know and i think that that's
that's actually going to be
something that we should spend more time
thinking through as a construct for you
know how this can help us govern the you
know kind of emergence of and use of
these new technologies in the future
yep absolutely so um uh in terms of the
autonomous systems of the systems that
are um exerting some of some control
over their own actions there's a couple
of different flavors and you talk about
a little bit in the book about you've
got essentially higher sophisticated
systems you've got like global hawks and
systems that are very expensive um
relatively small numbers of them they
can operate relatively independently and
do some of their own mission planning
and to respond to some of the stimuli in
the environment then you've got cheap
systems that are somewhat expendable
maybe even disposable
and they operate cert independently but
their scope of action is very
constrained you know they're not really
able to make a lot of decisions by
themselves
obviously there's a role for both of
those um what i'm curious about is when
you think about new ways of operating
that exploit
autonomous systems
unmanned systems how do you see the
relationship or how would you see both
of those families of unmanned systems
being used are they
are you looking to essentially are you
trying to do a like a war of attrition
uh ender's game i'm gonna throw a bunch
of disposable cheap things at somebody
and just overwhelm them
do you see that as being you know a
component of a larger force that maybe
uses that episodically but maybe the the
rest of the force is pursuing
a set of more traditional maneuver
actions and these expendable robots are
just an element of that um so i mean how
would you see the the different um
different types of unmanned systems
being employed in military operations as
opposed to um you know just to kind of
throw a bunch of human or robot waves at
people
yeah
so it's a great question i think the
um
perhaps the the sort of the point that
that
you know unifies the two um certainly in
the in the present sense is
um you know whether it's a global hawk
or something uh you know smaller and
cheaper um you know we we talk about
them as unmanned systems but they're
actually pretty exquisitely manned when
you really kind of look beneath the hood
and see all of the different particular
tasks that are being performed by human
beings remotely
in the case of many of these unmanned
systems
in order to make them operationally
useful and i think to me the the big
change is going to be
you know rather than having one unmanned
system or one man system that requires
you know an exquisite amount of human
beings behind it to make it um you know
operationally useful it's actually the
inversion of that command and control
relationship where you can now have a
single human being in command of large
quantities of systems
so you know to get at your question i
think you know the real opportunity here
is is kind of getting mass back on our
side
you know that for for many many many
years right we have made the choice
around you know kind of being
qualitatively superior even in the face
of you know kind of a quantitatively
superior adversary
um and we've been able to do that
because we've had you know kind of
exquisite technological overmatch that's
allowed us to hide evade detection
penetrate into enemy spaces
you know
fire a limited number of times but
exquisitely accurately
um so i mean to me i think you know the
opportunity of flipping this back to say
all right well from an operational
standpoint hiding is going to become
harder
i am going to have to
confront larger waves of systems coming
at me and i think autonomy really opens
up the possibility of being able to put
mass back on our side and to your point
yeah fight some of these um wars of
attrition you know smarter and cheaper
um you know than than maybe we had been
expecting to
um in terms of how that allows us to you
know to also then fight differently
other than just we're going to kind of
grind each other down and the last the
last person standing wins
which i think there's something to be
said for that
i do think the ability to operate faster
is going to be you know another critical
component of this right and you've
written you've written eloquently about
this in terms of sort of a
decision-centric model and that's
ultimately kind of why i focused on the
kill chain as an organizing concept of
the book which is you know it's it's
ultimately not the sort of particular
platforms or the pieces of the systems
that are interesting it's ultimately the
ability to
uh to understand what's going on to
rapidly make decisions and take relevant
actions um and and sort of increasing
the quantity and quality of that you
know the the speed and the scale by
which you can operate
where again as you've written you sort
of you you create so many different
dilemmas for the adversary that it just
fractures their ability to make
decisions
um i do think that is something that
autonomous systems are going to provide
us you know a real capability advantage
and sort of separate and apart from
basically just you know we're going to
grind each other down and at the end of
the day we're going to have more systems
on the battlefield than our competitor
which again is nothing to uh there's
nothing to scoff at i think as sort of
an operational outcome
yeah and yet we found in the war gaming
that we did looking at these kinds of
concepts is that uh the players um you
know they like the idea of being able to
do the attrition attack and just throw a
bunch of something at the at the
adversary and and overwhelm their
defenses um right but uh what they liked
is having the ability to do that as well
as um do some exquisite attacks that's
while the adversary is busy dealing with
the attrition um battle that's happening
you know elsewhere they can focus a
smaller number of platforms that still
might be autonomous but they're going to
go do the kind of pinpoint strikes
against the command and control nodes
the long-range sensors the those
capabilities that are really the things
that are the game changers in terms of
the way the battle is going to proceed
so getting that decision advantage also
takes you know taking away his eyes
while simultaneously keeping his hands
busy was something that the in the war
games we found very uh helpful well just
to build on that i mean i think you know
the the point that i try to stress in
the book is that
um
you know what would be what's what's
best is really kind of putting the focus
on the outcomes that we're trying to
achieve rather than getting uh you know
kind of overly consumed with you know
what type of system is is actually going
to be most relevant um because again you
know i'm prepared to believe that you
know the the best answers to these
problems of how do you build the sort of
effective battle network that's going to
solve these operational problems uh it
could be all legacy systems used in new
ways it could be a mixture of sort of
old technologies and new technologies um
you know at the end of the day it could
be it could be all brand new things um
but at the end of the day it really
shouldn't matter sort of how you combine
these things but i think again in a
point you've made so well you have to be
able to combine them you know in a in a
more elegant a more dynamic way
um so that you can sort of uh build
these different battle networks that are
not just entirely all brand new things
or all you know kind of exquisite sort
of point-to-point connected openings
but really be able to get those
interesting kind of synergies between
you know
a 40 30 you know 50 year old platform um
and some brand a brand new autonomous
system that was developed yesterday
exactly
so let's talk a little bit about um
where the u.s has a competitive
advantage here so you uh kind of talk
about you know how you would actually
implement this kind of force and what we
could leverage in terms of the us
technological base um but also uh where
do you see that kind of the fundamental
advantages where the u.s would be able
to better exploit these emerging
technologies than an adversary like a
china
yeah i mean i think
in a lot of these technologies we still
you know as a nation still have you know
considerable advantages um and
considerable capability i think the
challenge is just
you know aligning the advantages and
capability that we do have with the
actual military problems that we're
facing and you know this is the sort of
uh you know familiar conundrum of how do
you get you know companies and
uh you know kind of founders and others
who are working in these technologies
that are really focused on kind of
commercial applications and not
interested
um or actively opposed to working on you
know kind of military problems um i
think that that is going to be a
conundrum for us um i think you know one
of the one of the biggest advantages
that the united states has is just you
know kind of the operational
expertise and excellence that we have in
the united states military
sort of separate and apart from the
technology areas is you know it's it's
um
you know it's it's hard to replace um
you know just
the amount of time that we have spent
you know solving operational problems
actually uh you know dealing with these
types of challenges in combat
um it's you know it's not something that
we should be overly reliant upon because
you know a lot of these problems are
going to be new and different
but from the standpoint of really
thinking about how you how you solve
operational problems how you kind of
bring the joint force together to do
that i think we have a lot of ability
there
but at the same time i think we need to
be realistic that
you know there are a lot of aspects of
you know how china is going to develop
and use these technologies that could
very well give it a leg up over us you
know when it comes to scale when it
comes to data collection and retention
yeah
certainly when it comes to being uh you
know shall we say less interested in
some of the ethical concerns that i
think you know we spend a lot of time uh
rightly focused on
um you know that when you have a
government that's sort of founded on a
distrust of its own people
my sense is they're going to be a lot
more willing to kind of delegate these
types of decisions to autonomous
machines than the united states is
um so i think it is going to be you know
a long-term competition where
uh you know we we will have to look for
areas of advantage and you know we may
not always be the the sort of the leader
in these areas the question is how
quickly can we you know bring these
technologies in and integrate them into
the force to make them operationally
relevant uh
i think that's something that you know
we we actually have done quite well in
recent years but you know this is a this
is a very different type of challenge
and you know we need to be mindful of
the fact that you know much of what
we've learned over the past 20 years may
not all be transferable to this uh you
know kind of great power competition era
so
one interesting thing that comes out of
the way you were describing how unmanned
systems or autonomous systems might get
used and how some of the war gaming that
we did uh played out
was that if you are going to use your
unmanned systems to try to gain a
decision decision advantage meaning
you're going to use them to be able to
operate faster operate faster in time
but also faster by operating that scale
and giving the adversary more things to
look at so if you can speed up your
decision cycle and improve its quality
like that and you know hopefully you're
creating enough deception and enough um
you know confusion on the adversary side
that he's slowing his own decision cycle
um then it seems like you would one
thing we maybe will rely on this mission
command so the idea that a u.s force has
been trained in such a way that they are
willing to improvise
use their own initiative when
communications are lost they're willing
to accept
tactics that might not ordinarily be
what they would turn to based on
doctrine
so it seems like those those uh the
willingness of u.s leaders to be able to
take advantage of of their own
initiative and ability to improvise
might be an advantage if you're looking
at a decision-centric fight where you're
having to kind of use your own unmanned
systems that are under your command to
come up with a a tactic in the absence
of a planning staff or some higher
direction
yeah yeah definitely it seems like that
might be a form of competitive advantage
as well i i think that's right i mean i
think the challenge is you know the
united states military is going to have
to relearn a lot about mission command
as well but i think to your point you
know we're much better positioned to do
that than
uh you know an adversary that's very
top-down you know there was sort of an
inherent distrust in the lower ranks
um you know i think that is a that is
100
um you know kind of an advantage that we
have but you know that's something that
we're also going to have to relearn
after you know 20 years where we
certainly practiced a lot of mission
command in a lot of places but that
wasn't necessarily uh you know the way a
lot of these these conflicts were
structured
right that's right so but that brings me
to um a point that i think a lot of
people will ask is um how do we actually
uh make this transition so um you
discussed and we've discussed in our own
writings uh on this subject that uh you
don't have to transition to this
robot force of autonomous systems right
away you know this could be an element
of the force that gets gradually built
up over time and even a 10 percent
contribution to the force of unmanned
systems or autonomous systems makes a
big difference in your operational
outcomes um but how do we uh other than
just going back to the defense
contractors and saying
you know building a bunch of unmanned
systems are there better ways that dod
could be um trying to take advantage of
this enormous tech industrial base in
the united states to try to field
unmanned systems uh and ai enabled
command and control you know management
tools uh more quickly than it would if
it goes through the normal acquisition
pipeline
yeah it's um to me i mean this is the
sort of 64 million dollar question um
you know it's it's certainly one thing
to talk about all of this uh you know i
think the much harder challenge is how
to do it
and again that was you know something
that really kind of hit home for me and
was really eye-opening in the course of
doing the book is
um
how so many of the things that we are
now saying are things that we have said
over the past 20 to 30 years
um you know network-centric warfare i
mean it all sort of rings true and very
similar to
you know i think many of the things that
are being said and written now and you
kind of have to go back and ask why did
we fail to do or not do so many of the
things that we said were so important
you know for so many years
part of it i think is
um
we haven't gotten the incentives right
and that was kind of a main emphasis
that i put in the book um
you know i'm a big believer in
incentives and i think to a large extent
you know we've gotten exactly what we've
paid for um and i think the way that you
begin to change that is you have to
focus on
uh the actual things that you're trying
to buy um you know so
i'm a big baseball fan um you know a big
fan of the shift to sabermetrics where
we're now measuring team outcomes rather
than sort of player inputs
i think in much the same way you know
getting into a position where
we're actually competing out the things
that we are trying to do measured based
on the outcomes that we're trying to
achieve
so that there's an actual process and a
root you know kind of a repetitive
process every year
with a certain amount of money held in
sort of reserve uh kind of at the
beginning of the year by the senior
leaders of the department of defense the
congress's support to say
you know we are trying to sort of reduce
the time to close kill chains we're
trying to kind of uh you know enhance
the
decision-making advantage of of us
forces
you know we need to measure it against
specific operational problems that those
forces are going to have to confront
we have to get away from these kinds of
broader buzzwords like joint all-domain
command and control or multi-domain
operations which you know we can sort of
have an informed debate about what they
mean but you know you have to really
boil them down to the specific military
problems that you're going to have to
solve under the conditions that you're
going to have to solve them
against real world adversaries uh you
know not sort of uh you know general
sort of generalized competitors
and i think that if you actually begin
competing that out every year
um
you haven't you have an ability to see
what is performing best and i think
that's the best way to kind of navigate
this transition where initially
look much of that force is going to be
our legacy force right um and then the
question is going to be how can these
technologies enable that legacy force to
um you know to be faster to scale you
know more significantly
um
and that'll be you know the question of
how technology enables you know kind of
current operations current force
um and eventually you know you'll start
to see areas where uh new technologies
new capabilities will replace uh legacy
systems because they're capable of
performing better as part of that
integrated battle network
but unless you're measuring the thing
you're actually trying to do
um you know then it's just sort of you
know every man for himself and it
doesn't really
you know it doesn't really get you the
kind of data driven outputs that you
want so that you can direct you know
what is ultimately i think going to be a
decreasing amount of resources toward
the force you're trying to build um and
i think you know the other piece of that
is that it begins to create the
incentives for industry
to really understand that if they put
their own money towards solving these
problems they have a path to getting in
to
you know actually have a merit-based
competition where uh you know if they go
out and fund uh you know a new battle
management system or a new uh aircraft
or weapon
there's actually the prospect that the
department of defense has a mechanism
and the congress has a mechanism for on
ramping that at scale very quickly
and by the way you know if someone shows
up with a better capability than you
this year you know don't worry because
you'll have the opportunity to come back
and compete next year
this won't work for everything right i
mean you're you're going to be limited
uh yeah with larger more capital
intensive programs like aircraft
carriers and the like um you know but
there should just be a lot more attempt
to sort of put competition back into
not in the sense we mean sort of
acquisition competition at the front end
but constant operational competition to
determine what are the systems that you
should actually be putting resources in
uh and scaling them pretty considerably
so that
you know again you you begin to see that
the department of defense is moving
money toward the things that they
actually say are important um you know
and i think that's the thing that you
know that i look at and certainly looked
at from my time on the hill is that you
know what senior leaders what senior
members of congress say is interesting
what they spend money on is actually
what is going to move the needle in
terms of programmatic choices and then
investment choices on the part of uh on
the part of private industry and the
investment community
so it brings up that brings up a couple
of very interesting points that was a
fascinating uh discussion right there so
one is uh requirements so the department
of defense builds requirements today
essentially using a system engineering
approach where it determines how it
thinks it's going to be configured in
the future it determines what it thinks
the future scenarios are likely to look
like
and then they do essentially a analysis
to figure out what are the capability
gaps you know given that that assumption
for how i'm going to fight the
assumptions for what that threat looks
like and the assumptions for what my
available forces will look like in 20 20
years from now so there's a bunch of
assumptions built into it but it and
it's to come up with a point solution uh
what you're talking about is a very
different which is not a point solution
that you're driving toward but instead
you're more of a bottom-up
attempt to uh improve mission outcomes
so the
defense would establish here's missions
we think are important here's outcomes
we want to have happen here's a range of
environments in which those environ
those those outcomes are needed you know
so
china and the south china sea or you
know
in the baltic or something um and it
sounds like so it sounds like that's
what that's you're talking about here so
it's much more of a that the joint staff
comes up with outcomes and mission uh or
military problems they want to address
and then a lot of the job of the
department of defense is to
harvest ideas and assess their ability
to improve those outcomes
yeah i i think that's exactly right you
said it very well um you know i think
that unless we are actually focusing on
you know kind of the joint outcomes that
we're trying to achieve you know we're
going to end up buying a bunch of things
that may or may not actually achieve
those outcomes and i think you know part
of my problem with the requirements
process you know quote unquote
um
is just the degree of hubris i think
that's kind of baked into it which is
somewhat befitting right i mean the
experience that we've just had if you
know 30 years post-cold war sort of top
of the heap
um
but i just don't think that's really
going to hold up for us in the future um
you know like it's kind of a hackneyed
example but you know if i had to let my
own requirements for my mobile device
i'd have the best flip phone in america
right now
um like we've got to get beyond this
idea that if it's not invented in the
defense establishment or cooked up
inside of the department of defense it's
somehow no good
um i'd much be i'd be much more
interested in
you know every year being able to say
look i have to
um
you know i have to be able to defend uh
forward bases from large quantities of
incoming weapons i don't care how i do
that i don't care with what i do that
the question is you know can can we
field a better solution that you know uh
you know reduces the likelihood that my
forward bases are smoking holes in the
ground 48 hours into the startup
conflict
and focusing on that outcome and then
the capabilities that would come
together as as the thing that are really
going to drive the expensive resources
expense of resources not expensive
resources but it'll probably require
that too um and just iterating on that
so that every year there's an
understanding of you know whatever wins
is going to get funded
and we're going to come right back and
figure out if there's a better way to do
this next year and it's going to
significantly move
the needle on the money that we're
spending
so that kind of raises the question of
you know intellectual property rights
and how do we um design software or
essentially software so that companies
can have that opportunity to compete and
win the contract next year even if they
didn't win it this year because you're
going to have a system that's already
been developed or some parts of a system
of systems that you're going to need to
introduce your capability into
so and you don't you want to incentivize
companies to do this so you don't want
to tell them where you're going to get
to give up all your ip
in the process of competing in this
effort to try to provide systems to the
us government so um
there's lots of opportunities to try to
create a a model or a environment where
companies can retain their intellectual
property rights while also um modifying
systems on a very regular basis have you
been thinking about that i mean this is
probably something andrew deals with
um in terms of bringing in other
people's systems and trying to integrate
those with your own
yeah and i think it's um i mean to me
this is one of the core problems that
we're going to have to solve and i think
you know the department is very right to
you know criticize industry or i would
argue sort of criticize itself
um you know for for too often in recent
years kind of becoming beholden to
proprietary solutions from industry
where they've been locked in black boxes
that they've been incapable of sort of
you know updating themselves out of
and sort of moving at the speed that
technology is allowing them to move
that's all true and valid my concern is
that the backlash against that is going
to lead toward the belief that well it
should all just be government owned
right right as if we would say you know
well our our experience of the f-35 has
been a real downer so you know the
government is going to build its own
high-performance aircraft from that one
i mean it's just nonsense um i i think
the
the the real challenge is figuring out
what are the parts of that architecture
that the government is going to have to
own and define to ensure that uh you do
have sort of openness scalability
extensibility
in the future
so things like you know the applications
programming interfaces
reference architecture
to a certain extent standards you know
those are things that the government is
going to have to i think define
but then really kind of allow industry
to to be entrepreneurial and creative
about how they how they bring solutions
to bear
again i don't think it's terribly
difficult i mean you know i think the
way we saw this play out with the
commercial internet was you know you had
a handful of the major movers you know
get together and sort of hammer out a
set of architectures and standards
and then sort of iteratively iteratively
improve it as we go you know which is
why
you know i have an apple computer right
now that's i think running you know a
google application
um you know while i'm writing microsoft
word documents um you know that nobody
mandated that that had to be so it was
mostly just kind of creating the
incentives for people to play together
um in a way that you know then people
can develop applications on top of that
these new things can uh can be developed
without a sense of i have to know
exactly what the future is going to look
like in 10 years and build toward that
right
i mean it hasn't worked well for us when
we've tried to do that in the past and
it's only going to get worse if we keep
trying to do it in the future um it's
mostly i think trying to determine what
are the core things that the government
really has to define uh to really turn
industry and sort of the private uh you
know the private sector loose on these
problems in a way that
uh you get the best capability you get
an evolving rapidly evolving capability
uh but at the end of the day you know
they the government
can still have confidence that all of
this stuff is going to come together and
cohere you know the same way when i buy
a new sensor for my house i can plug it
into the you know kind of the
architecture that i'm running in uh you
know in my environment here um
it's it's totally doable and i mean this
is the thing that i kind of come back to
in the book is like this isn't
witchcraft i mean like you know this is
things that the united states military
and service members are doing every day
in their private lives there's no reason
why we can't do this in defense and yet
we're 10 years behind where the
commercial world is in this respect
yeah and and um to kind of close out
here it seems like one of the things
we'll have to do is uh incentivize
industry also from a financial
perspective you know so we can make it
easier for new commercial or for new
players to enter and offer solutions to
these military problems um but they're
used to getting you know 20
time returns so they're they're used to
vc money being used to to uh support you
know 10x and 20x returns uh and if
you're getting
you know 10
uh returns that's probably not a very
successful use of vc money so companies
that are from that world are going to
have difficulty seeing the value and and
trying to compete for dod dollars is
there a way that the dod or the
government can better incentivize those
companies that are used to much higher
returns on the commercial side
um i i think that they can definitely do
better as far as creating better
incentives
but i think the reality is that look i
mean working working in the defense
space you're not going to get the kind
of returns that you know a commercial
software startup is going to get
um so i think to a certain extent you
know there's just going to there's going
to need to be kind of a baseline set of
expectations that um you know maybe you
can do better than the you know
two or three percent you know that sort
of traditional industry is returning
um but you're not going to get to the 20
the 20 returns that you know kind of
commercial software is going to get
right
i think that's a doable proposition but
i think again from the government
standpoint they need to get out of this
mentality that
you know they so value uh cost certainty
and sort of controlling the profits of
industry that they would rather pay a
billion dollars for something and know
that industry only got two and a half
percent profit as opposed to pay 400
million dollars you know with industry
getting 20 profit
you know at the end of the day we need
to be you know kind of aligned toward
what's really important here
but i think you know from the standpoint
of creating those incentives
you know you're going to see a lot more
companies and engineers and
technologists and investors
interested in being involved in national
defense if the government is actually
buying the emerging technologies that
they say are important that these
companies and you know
founders and investors want to put in uh
want to build
um
so i honestly i mean i think we we
overthink a lot of this from the
standpoint of
you know
why is silicon valley or why is the
technology community not doing more with
respect to the dod and i think a lot of
it boils down to
look if you were if you were actually
buying and deploying this technology at
scale you would see a lot more engineers
who thought they could make a successful
career doing national defense work you'd
see a lot more companies getting founded
and you'd see a lot more private
investment going into
modernizing national defense as opposed
to you know optimizing advertising
algorithms for you know social media
there's a there's a degree of supply and
demand here and you know the government
needs to create that demand
and i think if they do and actually put
money behind what's important um you'll
you'll slowly but nonetheless i think
significantly start to see industry
respond in traditional industry too
um you know i mean part of the thing
that i that i raise in the book is you
kind of look at a lot of these uh you
know kind of earlier attempts at
unmanned systems autonomous systems
aircraft weapons things that are you
know struggling for funding for years
they get canceled prematurely
that doesn't exactly send a strong
incentive to traditional industry that
this is something that they should
really be prioritizing in their
portfolio when uh you know uh their
traditional offerings are are getting
funded and considerable you know
considerably you know larger increments
right
absolutely
uh well thank you chris thank you very
much for being with us today um
chris rose chief strategy officer for
andrew industries uh most recent book uh
the kill chain um defending america and
the future of high tech warfare
and it's available right now um i'm sure
it's available many places as in in
addition to amazon which was right i
think i got my copy um thank you very
much chris for being with us today uh
and uh good luck on the book
excellent well thanks for having me and
thanks for everything that you're doing
um it's a pleasure to chat with you and
as i hope you saw in the book um you
know there's there's a lot of that
that's got your fingerprints and
influence all over it so
um i i will i will uh give you credit
where credit is due but i will take all
the blame for things that i mangled and
got wrong but honestly it's a pleasure
to be with you and appreciate the
opportunity
thank you it's great having you on and
uh thank you very much everyone for
being with us today um uh this is brian
clark for the hudson institute signing
out and uh stay safe thanks
here's a look at some publishing
industry news jonathan carp has been
named